hey I can't get rid of it oh hey who who
what somebody on
yeah what's up hey uh hey uh Obi wait am
I gonna get my glasses on here
what the hell I can't figure out this
thing is Obi around no we're doing a
podcast or did you did you mean to click
this link who wait a minute who the hell
are you guys first of all get Opie for
her birthday
um we're we're just holding it we're
just holding an open Forum to discuss
um the local penis statue being placed
in Los Angeles wait wait is this the is
this the apartment is this the apartment
yes
I I can't something find out what
they're talking about what are they
doing
how does this thing work Kathy I can't
figure this out I'm trying to wish Obi
happy birthday uh what what are your
names I'm Cody Noel
Cody come on what's your real name man
[__] you